1876 his history of America's founding
year is in its 28th week on the
bestseller list
Al Franken is in the ninth slot with his
critique of the Bush administration the
truth with jokes James Frey rounds out
the top ten my friend Leonard details
his friendship with a mobster for more
information visit the New York Times
website at nytimes.com and click on
books in pornified Pamela Paul argues
that women are being urged to embrace
pornography in today's culture she's one
of several authors at this panel about
the current state of sexuality in
America hosted by new school University
in New York City portions of this our
40-minute program contain language that
some may find offensive you all have the
buyers for tonight's speakers so I'm not
gonna go too into depth but I do want to
introduce them all briefly we're
thrilled that they could be here with us
tonight it's a very accomplished
talented panel we're thrilled that they
took the time to come here tonight and
talk about this very interesting and
provocative topic starting on my left
breast on my left pamela paul is the
author of born of both pornified how the
culture of pornography is transforming
our lives our relationships and our
families and the starter marriage in the
future of matrimony
a journalist pamela is a contributor to
Time magazine and is written for
numerous numerous publications including
The Economist the New York Times Book
Review and Psychology Today
she speaks frequently on TV and radio
about issues related to marriage and
divorce social and demographic trends
and generational issues nadine strossen
nadine is a law professor at New York
law school and since 1991 has been the
first woman to serve as president of the
American Civil Liberties Union named by
numerous magazines over the years as one
of the most influential women in meat in
America nadine writes extensively and
spends much of her time traveling and
speaking to groups in the US and abroad
as well as appearing on TV news shows
and talk radio she's the author of
defending pornography free speech sex
and the fight for women's rights Nelson
George is a writer and cultural critic
and has written numerous fiction Anand
books including hip-hop America night
work and he was co-writer Russell
Simmons autobiography life and death his
story it's never too late in New York
appeared in Susie brights collection of
best American erotic tour 2005 and also
a filmmaker Nelson was an investor in
Spike Lee she's got to have it in as
several films of his own including to be
a black man with Samuel Jackson and a
documentary a great day in hip hop area
levy Ariel is a writer for New York
Magazine and her work has also appeared
in Vogue slate Men's Journal and blender
magazine's
she's a author of the recently released
book female chauvinist pigs women in the
rise of raunch culture quejaime wits is
the William e Simon fellow at the
Manhattan Institute and a contributing
editor of the city journal she's a
principal contributor to modern sex
liberation and its discontents and his
author of Liberation's children parents
and kids in a postmodern age K is
written for many publications including
the New York Times The Washington Post
in The Wall Street Journal and Katy
Ornstein is an award-winning author
journalist and cultural critic
who writes on women's politics popular
culture mythology human rights in Haiti
her work has appear in the New York
Times The Washington Post MS magazine
among other places and she's the author
of Little Red Riding Hood uncloaked
sex morality and the evolution of a
fairy tale and Katy's moderated several
conversations with us so I'm going to
turn the conversation over to her thank
you can everyone hear me I don't sound
as loud as I thought I would well first
of all I just want to thank Rebecca and
the Center for communications this is
I've had a number of opportunities to
work with Rebecca and Katherine and a
lot of you probably know about the
Center for communications if you don't
though and if you've come for other
reasons I I would say check out their
website it's a great organization and
these panels have always been fantastic
so thanks to them and also thanks to all
the panelists and thanks to all of you
for coming I really apologize for the
people who are sitting behind me and I
think because it's being filmed I'm not
sure if I can turn my chair can i does
anyone know I I can't apologize so it's
a huge audience I hope none of you
thought we were actually going to be
showing porn tonight anyone wants to
leave now
so we're bringing together a panel of
social critics and activists and civil
libertarians and producers of culture to
discuss the meaning and consequences of
porn to not actually show porn and while
I was preparing for this panel I went
and looked back at some of the other
panels on pornography and and related
themes that have taken place over the
years and 20 years ago or roughly in
1984 Harper's Magazine hosted a panel on
this very topic in this it would have it
in this actual same spot and it was 1984
and only a few short months before the
panel Vanessa Williams the reigning Miss
America found herself displayed on the
pages of Penthouse magazine and looking
back at the press coverage of that I was
sort of amazed to see how scandalous it
was because today appearing in a porn
video is is the sort of thing that
actually made Paris Hilton a celebrity
and still even then the moderator of
that panel it was mark Danner amidst all
the public outrage at penthouse for
exploiting Vanessa Williams at Vanessa
Williams for being so naive and and at
the pageant committee for forcing her to
give up her crown it's worth noting that
that issue of penthouse was actually the
the greatest selling the best-selling
issue that they had ever done six
million people bought the issue and so
in 1984 there was still a lot of porn
but somehow it was a little bit more
taboo and so today we're gonna talk
about the ways that pornography has
evolved and become a part such a part of
our culture a pornified culture as
pamela calls it in her book and what
that means and the questions that I'm
gonna ask are really grouped into three
sets first what is the nature of
pornography today what what is
pornography is everything if pornography
is part of everyday life what really is
porn and what's not and second what is
the impact of pornography how is our
modern technology poor enhanced
fortified culture shaping us and third
what if anything should we do about it
and so I thought maybe we can start with
Pamela because in your book
you often mention that people who talk
about porn or support porn may not
realize what it actually is today is is
porn qualitatively different today from
20 years ago say even back then there
were misconceptions and
misrepresentations of what pornography
is we tend to conflate pornography with
sex and say well if you're
anti-pornography you must be anti sex we
tend to think that pornography is
harmless entertainment we have a
perception of pornography that I think
it really differs from the reality
especially when you look at what it was
20 years ago and I think that there's an
entire generation out there the baby
boomers and and those who are older who
still think of pornography in terms of
gauzy Playboy centerfolds and probably
haven't spent a lot of time particularly
on the internet but also on satellite
cable television and in print media
looking at the way in which pornography
has evolved and I think that you know as
it has in the past technology has really
pushed pornography and vice versa
the kind of chicken-and-egg situation
but it's pushed it to new extremes and
it's I think disingenuous to talk about
pornography as mere sexual expression or
as a celebration of sex when if you look
at what's actually out there and it
doesn't take a lot of effort to do so
you can go online it takes about 10
minutes to get a pretty good sense what
you see is often a very negative
representation a commercialized
representation of a particular point of
view about sex and it's often a very
negative view and what's ironic is when
you talk about pornography and you
critique it you are written off as a
prude or as anti sex and a lot of the
pornography is really prudish and anti
sex sex is depicted as something that's
dirty that needs to be over and done
with and sort of put away something
that's private the women in pornography
are often when they're depicted as being
sexually voracious there then punished
for their desires and so a lot of what
is actually in pornography I think is
quite anti sex what are we talking about
exactly what are the extremes that we're
talking about what are the things that
people who talk about porn don't know
about porn today
well we're on c-span what can I say I'll
try to bring out my euphemisms one of
the interesting things when I was
conducting
the interviews that I did for my book
which work primarily with men interviews
that often lasted for days because
surprisingly to me men were very eager
to talk about pornography they hadn't
actually asked themselves well what is
it that I like about the three Asian
women in the bathtub or you know why do
I like to see women tortured and and
multiple penetration scenes in which the
woman is picked as unwilling and one of
the things that surprised me is I asked
a question of everyone that I
interviewed do you like [ __ ] and
nobody said what's that and I'll just
try to politely describe what [ __ ] is
it's a Japanese form of pornography it's
now very popular in the United States
there's huge subgenres of [ __ ] but
the main component is it depicts
multiple men ejaculating on a woman's
face and she's shown crying during this
and that's become enormous ly popular I
heard answered many men admitted to
enjoying this a lot of them would you
know sort of give specifics well I don't
like it when it's you know too many men
or I like it when she's crying but then
she sort of seems happy afterwards but
it's again I think very different from
what most people think of when they
think about porn and they think oh you
know just depictions of consensual sex
and that this is sort of a happy
liberated view of sexuality but in
general you're you're making an argument
in your book that pornography has become
very extreme well you know it's it's
it's not only my argument it's actually
something that purveyors of pornography
will openly admit when you talk to
people and what people say at the Adult
Video News forum you know when you look
at pornography you become inured to sort
of the basic images it's like any kind
of form of entertainment you know when
you look at a violent movie you know
just to see a plain old car crash isn't
very exciting to audiences anymore you
have to see the car crash into a truck
and it has to be on a railroad track
with a helicopter flying overhead in
order to elicit any kind of response
from the viewer and the same thing
happens with porn it has to become more
and more extreme in order to continue to
contain users interests and this is
something that pornographers know and
they say openly yes it's gotten a lot
more extreme and we
we have to do this because this is what
the audience wants and when I talk to
men about the way in which they are they
use pornography the vast majority of
them said you know I started off with
print and frankly once I got into video
online especially the print was really
boring and I just it just didn't get me
off anymore and once they got into video
then it wasn't just one on one they had
to see group sex then they had to see
very often a demeaning or violent
component to it whether that was genital
torture or SNM or some you know rape the
reenactments it depends on the taste of
the particular user but they often
remarked you know for themselves that
they did tend to upgrade not only in how
often they wanted to look at it or
needed to look at it but in the kind of
pornography that they sought out just
I'll go along the line here Nadine when
we were talking on the phone about your
book defending pornography you said to
me that that wasn't wasn't your
preferred choice of title and that you
would have rather had it be defending
free speech and one of the things you
pointed out that was that was that free
speech is a tool that can be used by
pornographers or feminists alike and
that the that censorship is something
that's also been used in recent cases to
for example seize feminist literature or
gay literature and my question for you
is given what Pamela's described is
there anything in the way that
pornography has evolved that concerns
you or anything that's changed in the
last 20 years that would make a civil
libertarian think twice absolutely not
and and the reason I made the disclaimer
to Katie about the somewhat misleading
title of the book that I as a first-time
author didn't have the free speech right
to choose the title is unlike other
panelists here I'm not a cultural critic
I don't pretend to have any expertise
about the precise content of what is
available let alone who is looking at
what for me what is at stake is a
principle that absolutely does not
change that is defending freedom of
choice for all mature men
women both to perform for whatever they
choose to perform for right if any of
those women were or men was forced or
coerced even subtly of course that's a
violation of their civil liberties but
if they are choosing affirmative ly to
earn their living that way that is also
their freedom and I also defend freedom
for all mature individuals to make their
own decisions about what they choose to
see and read so the only limit is with
respect to children you know very image
to our children cannot make their own
choices I say very immature because when
you get to be teenagers certainly you do
have the right to go online to look at
what some people might well condemn as
pornography and I know that that P word
which have a not bad P word the
four-letter key word is which has no
legal definition at all is a word that
everybody uses to describe whatever it
is that they don't like in the realm of
the sexually explicit it has become an
epithet as one whit put it what turns me
on is erotica what turns you on is
pornography and that said I defend the
right of all these people to choose no
matter how disgusting other people might
I find the images to be so the principle
absolutely has not changed at all and I
do have to say that that P word epithet
has been used against Planned
Parenthood's website and websites that
give information about lesbian and gay
sexuality about websites that give
information and to women about their
reproductive health and options so we
have to be very very careful if we let
the standard up some people think it's
offensive become a standard and I
understand you're not advocating
censorship but that's why I say we can't
tolerate censorship no matter how
offensive some images might be to some
of us so I had a conversation with
Arielle before this panel we talked
about the difficulty of the problem of
actually invoking porn when you're
critiquing it and the problem of you
know what do you say and what do you not
say and I want ever
to feel free to use whatever euphemism
they want but I also find it somewhat
absurd if we don't allow ourselves also
to use the words that I'm sorry we're
free because one of the broadcast sweeps
but not on cabe right so I'm not
actually clear which keywords you were
talking about they're just I'm not sure
[Laughter]
when we were talking on the phone you
you brought up the ACLU use definition
of what we're the line for regulation
would be which is an intentional
incitement to imminent violence that's
not only the ACL u--'s definition that
is actually the standard that the United
States Supreme Court has used that no
expression whether it's sexual
expression pornography or anything else
is absolutely protected but where the
line is drawn is if there is some very
serious harm that is going to because
immediately by the expression and there
is no less restrictive way of preventing
the harm other than suppressing the
speech so the classic kinds of harm our
intentional incitement to imminent
violence and the famous example you've
all heard is falsely shouting fire in a
crowded theater right and then we caused
a panic and some of you might get
trampled and the other classic example
is a threat right because even a threat
that where the person who receives the
threat yeah
reasonably believes that it is in that
it's serious because then you
immediately feel as if you're harmed
your freedom of movement is already
impaired and I don't think either of
those applies to any sexual expression
my follow-up question really is if so
that's a clear distinction but what
happens when the culture is there a
point where the culture moves in such a
direction that it's very hard to
distinguish what that would be I mean if
you have a culture that's if if you by
Pamela's arguing
we have a truly Porta fide culture and
that that that pornography has become as
she describes it in her book incredibly
hardcore an incredibly mainstream have
we not move to a point where that
perception of danger or assault is now
something that we just accept implicitly
that we don't even question or notice
anymore is there a point there there is
a really clear distinction between
saying our culture is changing in such a
way that women are degraded and
therefore men have a negative attitude
toward women and therefore it's more
likely to that a man may commit an
assault against a woman all of that
speculative reasoning about some
potential harm sometime in the future is
not a justification for suppressing
speech that used to be it's called the
bad tendency speech right speech might
have a bad tendency that might at some
point in the future lead to bad
attitudes that might lead to bad conduct
if that was the standard that was used
back in the early 20th century when we
were censoring socialists and communists
because that expression might lead to
disrespect for capitalism which might
lead to an overthrow of the United
States government if we have that much
of an attenuated connection between this
speech and the potential harm concrete
harm then we'd have no free speech at
all so really what the law demands and I
think it's completely appropriate is a
tight and direct causal connection
between the speech there's no time to
intervene to change people's attitudes
to come forward with more positive
images and we also realize that human
beings are independent agents the fact
that they seeing him and doesn't mean
it's going to have immediately
translated into how that person acts I'm
gonna skip over and come back to you
just because that seems to me a nice
segue into to our own and what your
argument is in your book one of the
things that you talk about in your book
is the way that pornography has just
permeated our culture and what is the
line now between pornography and say a
cardio striptease class that you break a
crunch
or jenna jameson on the bestseller list
or strip stripper poles in your bedroom
or any of the millions of other examples
that you give and you're waiting one of
the things that you pointed out which I
found really interesting was that Traci
Kwon who is used to write a column for
salon right uh-huh
and she has a book of a diary about how
Barnes & Noble with William Rehnquist
and then afterwards if that's not being
part of the establishment I don't know
what is so my question for you is you
your definition of raunch culture is
really it's like a hotness definition
which you define is sort of sexy and
consumerist looks like I'm even sloppier
you know she was saying that like people
who say what I like is erotica what you
like is porn
I'm even sloppier than that I just said
okay I mean I can make up a word that
sort of covers just this spread of the
aesthetic and the ethos of you know porn
or a red-light district into the
mainstream and so now we have raunchy
culture well is there a distinction now
between pornography and everything else
that you talked about in your book I
mean what is pornography is pornography
is everything well that's like a tree
falls in the forest kind of course like
I mean I think that pornography is sort
of in its in its ethic the inspiration
for so much of what I see in the culture
I mean I think what was sort of
interesting and disturbing to me about
the culture right now is how much we've
sort of emphasized performance as
opposed to personal pleasure in what we
view as sexuality and I think that you
know if that's the way you're thinking
about sex then it makes perfect sense
that jenna jameson is gonna be on the
best in case anybody doesn't know jenna
jameson is the top-selling adult film
star and planet Earth and so you know if
if that's if you're thinking about
performance or not pleasure she's who
you want to read on the bestseller list
Paris Hilton who is you know going to be
your social emblem we want on the cover
of Vanity Fair you're gonna go to the
gym for Carter your striptease classes
because you know what we're doing is
imitating women whose job it is to fake
lust so I mean to me
the difference between you know the
panel that they had here back then with
but at that point corn and anything
related to it was really seen as
something private and kind of trashy and
even when inside deep throat came out
and you know there were articles in the
newspaper about corn chic it was still
something that feminists you know we're
picketing outside the theaters whereas
now you have women actively embracing
this trend and and participating not
just by you know flashing for girls gone
wild but being behind the cameras to
making a lot of these cultural products
as well so that's I was interested in
why women are embracing this now why
we've sort of taken everything that
feminism once reviled and decided to
rename it you know and we
reappropriation of our liberation I mean
I think that even if you were a feminist
and you were you know however you want
to put it pro sex pro porn I think you
still probably were interested in the
idea that there should be a multiplicity
of ways female sexuality can be
conceived of and represented and I think
what we've done now is boiled it down to
something extremely commercial you know
it's this particular in particularly
commercial shorthand for sexiness so
it's not that it should be censored you
know I'm starting from everything you
said to me it's like obviously you're
right but why why why are why are we
holding this up as the ultimate in
earthy sexuality when it's really you
know polyester implants and I mean
polyester Underpants and implants rather
it's not a particularly titillating
smoldering very view of sexuality in my
modest opinion mm-hmm so one of the
things that I want to go back to Nelson
now what cuz one of the things that I
think is really interesting is the
transfer of pornography from something
that is assuming lemay all terrain to
something that's been in your book at
least totally feminized appropriated
whether it whether in terms of
liberation are or old objectification or
whatever it is somehow incredibly
feminized and I I noticed it in my own
peer group which is why your book was so
interesting it didn't seem to me like
some far-off thing that's happening for
a small sector of the population it
seemed to me that something it's
something that's very recognizable even
in my own
own take on culture erotica pornography
whatever and really sort of opened my
eyes well there's been some sort of
transfer where I'm viewing something
that would have been seen as trashy yeah
trashy or old-fashioned and unliberated
and now I'm looking at it in this
different very different way and I and
it was the first time really well maybe
this year really but when your book came
it really that I've begun to start
questioning why that is and that I want
to bring the question of transfer to go
back to Nelson oh you know listen
everyone speak here maybe I'm slightly
different take on it everyone's like a
porno as the model for why the culture
has moved and maybe what I'm about to
say relates to that as a direct
correlation but I say stripping to me
stripper culture I don't see young girls
wanted to be porn stars
I do see young girls wanted to be
strippers and stripper stripper culture
has an economic component to it that is
stripping has become a way for
working-class girls to make money and to
move out of their conditions to feed
their kids and I've actually had debates
with high school girls about what they
wanted to do in the future and they said
they're gonna be strippers and and not a
couple of them I mean like a
considerable vintage who see it as a
stepping stone to other things I don't
find girls cent I want to be a porn star
because that's but a stripping thing
which is a step away perhaps it's
definitely permeated the culture a lot
of it comes to music the music video
culture that we sort of dovetails was to
increase in porn has glorified the
woman's body and the use of woman's body
in a very sexual way and I mean when I
was growing up if I said I never saw a
gyrating behind okay I mean maybe I'm
one of you know one Ed Sullivan Show to
be dancer there right but so maybe what
if you watch Soul Train you might have
seen a lot of generation now the same
kid who's thirty year old me sees
gyrations all day and in fact there's a
show on a be ET that comes on at night
called uncut which is basically the raw
Rasmussen's that comes in like two
o'clock in the morning it has phenomenal
ratings so
I don't have the porn thing for me it's
the stripping culture and and and part
of why it's so prevalent for among young
women and it spills over is a the music
video culture supports it highly
strippers but strippers can actually
tour other people really realized
strippers become is it they baits or as
much as comedians I know comedian
friends of mine who see strippers on the
road all the time because they go from
town to town making money going from
city to city so this is weird
I see this the connection between the
music videos the stripper culture the
economic drive that leads women to
become strippers and makes it a
legitimate business and and takes a
shame away from it and that begins the
effect the dancing I mean look at look
at all the great trilogy of the create
trilogy of American behinds Britney j.lo
and Beyonce I don't I think that had
more impact on the way women dress and
dance than jenna jameson because they're
there every day and they extinct there's
a point aesthetic perhaps in some of it
but also somebody is an extension of
social dance and in another kind of way
I mean the fact that girls can show
their g-string the same way guys show
their underwear you know is a big change
I don't get I don't know if that's porn
I see that more as this kind of sex is a
commodity but not the extreme of
commodity not the extreme of selling
their body
girls get argument you always get from
girls of strip is you know I'm in
control I guess that goes back to the
porn thing but they feel a lot of them
cut joy that line you're not going to go
that far right which is an interesting
line to draw really it's like all did
you make that point in your book area
that they'll do all the stuff that a
pornographer my pornstar might do but
won't actually be paid for it not
exactly that's what I say for in a sense
they feel safer because there's actually
security at some of these clubs and they
feel like there's a line there
the blurry line there the question then
is the impact on greater culture is the
same because the rhetorical sort of the
rhetorical significance of what these
women is are doing is the same
pornography pornstar Rob whatever it is
whether or not they're actually what
they do off screen is beside the point
what what they're representing the look
America has always been a hypocritical
culture about sex listen let's say that
I'm not I mean I grew up in a culture of
african-american culture where sex was
much more readily accepted that people
were sexy did women dress sexy it wasn't
it wasn't it there was a church side to
it there's a dichotomy gendered Sunday
church service in a Saturday night get
down
right but everyone respected satellite
get down as part of life it wasn't like
something it was hidden to the side that
people didn't get busy that people
didn't want to dress sexy white American
cultures had a lot harder time grasping
that idea of sexuality and so to me
what's happened is not necessarily a
negative in a sense that women are
beginning to a white women listen they
say embracing the sexuality more I do
think that the spectacle of it has
shaken people to amazing degree that's
the part of the rock-and-roll revolution
that's part of what hip-hop is brought
to the to play so we are in a more
sexual culture is it totally wrong is it
totally a bad thing I'm not totally sure
it is I do think that there are the
[ __ ] things
it's crazy anybody see [ __ ] knows
that that's like what is that it's
really crazy stuff so I mean I have
there's a line I won't go next that
[ __ ] stuff is definitely the part of
some other stuff but the sexual the
sexualization of the culture I'm not
totally I don't think that that's all
wrong or bad all right before I move on
I just want to say one of the things
that we talked about that was really
interesting to me was you know hip hop
which is something you know more about
them probably anyone I've met and it's a
it's a predominantly male genre with a
few exceptions and the reason that you
said is because the viewers of hip
hopera are private it's the main
audience is 15 to 25 year old men and I
quote you whose hornier than that
related to this discussion is most hip
hop records are purchased by white males
absolutely positive it's a known fact in
the reckon history and by a lot and just
when you have an Eminem or jay-z or
fill-in-the-blank guy selling over 1/2
million records they're selling
phenomenally to white males and with
young white women as well as part of
that so when you look at it Luther
Campbell we talked about earlier who's
actually the poster child for the
sexualization of hip hop you talking
about a guy whose appeal was not just
from for black kids in the hood but for
white frat boys and so again I go back I
think that the saturation of culture is
not just porn it's it's out there and in
many different forms in the culture and
again maybe because I'm a man I'm
necessarily against the idea of girls
waiting their behinds I don't think
that's a bad thing I do think that there
are our places where I think that we're
talking about is the most extreme parts
of it that freak people out and it
should but for our culture to be more
accepting of sexuality and all of his
aspects is something this America is
desperately needed
Elson mentioned Luther Campbell the
reason I knew about him was this was the
very first time in American history
that there was a an obscenity
prosecution a criminal prosecution of a
work of music and it was a famous to
Live Crew case the ACLU ultimately
successfully defended him but I think
that's very interesting given all the
sexualization of our culture even back
then that the target happened to be an
African American performer who was seen
as reaching a white audience absolutely
I mean you are familiar with my book you
know that I don't advocate censorship
and I think that the whole way in which
the debate has been framed between you
know banning it or exalting it I think
has really overlooked the true impact of
pornography but I'm curious about your
earlier discussion about obscenity we
were you didn't mention obscenity in
Miller versus California and how they
also defined for pornography although
they use the word obscenity and you said
that the one restriction on speech was
the you know the fire the hazards I'm
curious what how you view the Miller
versus California because
I was speaking to it was Rodney's Smola
and he said that basically when you look
at the pornography that's out there
today 80% of it would be prosecutable
under Miller versus California but it's
qualifies as obscenity so I'm interested
to know how I want to get back to that
question because I want to get okay but
I do think that's a great question and
it's still in the same line of what is
pornography today and what's obscene
today but I wanted to get to you okay
and also because we were talking about
the impact on young people and the
development pornography in the context
of how it shapes our identity and you've
written about that right I really want
to think about what it's like to come of
age in a pornified culture because as we
all know children are very influenced by
their surroundings and I want to make
the argument that you hear so often that
somehow if children are exposed to
anything these poor little innocent
creatures are going to be sullied or
corrupted I don't believe that at all
and you know this is probably dating me
but I remember when I when I was growing
up there was this book that was on my
parent's bookshelf that was faced in you
know so that she couldn't see the cover
but it was the it was the Kinsley Kensie
remember and that book was very well
thought through by the entire family I
happen to know I don't believe it did
did us did any and either me or my
brother's sister much harm so that's not
my argument my argument though is that
you know children are it's not that
they're innocent and I've raised three
kids so I know they're not in it but
they are unshaped
and they are ignorant and they are
trying they come into this world and
they're trying to figure out okay yeah
what are the rules what am I supposed to
make of this world and what concerns me
about this pornified culture is that the
message that's getting through to kids
is that we're supposed to think that sex
is like this now I don't I don't think
that the consequence of that is
necessarily that kids are going to get
to be 16 and then they're going to want
to imitate the [ __ ] see scenario
although maybe they will
but that I think that's almost too blunt
I don't know that there's a kind of
direct imitation that goes on always
sometimes I'm sure there is but the
bigger problem I think is what the
pornified culture says about sex and it
seems to me that it reduces sex to
something it's just merely about
physical pleasure completely divorced
from any kind of meaning or larger
emotional experience I well I'm going to
disagree with some of the other people
in the panel I don't think this is just
a product of porn I think this has been
developing ever since the sexual
revolution and feminism came on the
scene because the idea the ideal that
that we began to hear formulated at that
time was that the liberation had to do
with being independent autonomous
disconnected expressing yourself by
yourself and not what it meant was that
the partner or this the sexual partner
becomes a kind of tool or an object
that's the danger and something that I
think we see a lot of it seems to me
that the really difficult thing one of
the really difficult things about
growing up in this culture is finding a
way to become to be capable of intimacy
we take it for granted that that should
happen it's not a natural thing I think
it's a great individual and cultural
achievement when it happens and the
culture it seems to me has to be more
supportive of those kinds of
relationships because I think that's
where people find happiness and not from
being able to shake their booties I
think you know yeah that could be fun
sometimes that's fine but that's not
where the deeper sources of happiness
and meaning are and what concerns me is
that we get distracted by these images
of the you know the hot girl and the
launch of the raunch girls who
think well that's what it means to be
you know a cool girl today and then they
grow up and think that's what I want to
be that's what I should be images
reflect the culture as well as vice
versa that it's a cyclical kind of yes
but I think so my argument is always
about the culture and abet and it seems
to me that the what fascinated me about
about Pamela's book and Aries and
Ariel's actually is that we now are
hearing from a younger generation which
from my vantage point people are saying
we'll wait a minute what you know isn't
there another vocabulary here for so
long this discussion has been in these
kind of Scopes trial terms you know
either you are a flat earther you know
or John Ashcroft or an abstinence
promoter or or Comstock or something
like that you know or you're you know
you believe in freedom and those were
the only two possibilities and it seems
to me that what we're learning is that
the freedom by itself was not enough and
that the culture and by that I mean the
stories that are being told that the the
movies that are being made the images
that we see that the culture is not
supporting the possibility of a deeper
Richards experience so I want to talk in
a minute about about the impact and
maybe some prescriptions but for now I
just want to stick with definitions and
I want to ask you if you want to if you
want to add anything to that on what is
pornography for young people what are
the what are the specifics of experience
growing up in this sort of culture you
know I I don't have a definition for you
I mean it seems to me that the I'm more
comfortable just talking about a hyper
sexualized culture and talking about
that the effect on kids not specifically
about porn I think that we're making a
distinction here that maybe isn't
doesn't have as much importance maybe as
maybe we're so defined but I well maybe
I didn't ask that question well enough
but I think one of the things that
people especially people over 30 or over
40 are concerned with
people left children are particularly
are that children are so much more
technologically savvy in the in the
particular sorts of technologies that
that create and disseminate pornography
that how do adults even know what's
going on I mean you know what is what is
what does a few chip do you know
children you know it pretty much
everyone here on this panel is familiar
with this argument but the specifics of
it some of which are in your book you
know cell phone porn iPod porn the
technically you know internet from the
technology for experiencing this aspect
of culture is something that young
people have and that a lot of old people
don't or choose not to access right but
I think that the inevitably children's
experience of these things is mediated
by the family and by the broader culture
in other words if there is a clear
message coming from families from
schools from the culture at large that
this stuff is really marginal it's not
what we accept as the norm I think they
have a different experience of it again
I want to say it's not that they're
exposed to it you know the same way I
was reading that was as soon as I could
read I think you know I just you know
but I knew that that was something
different you know that was sort of a
part of life that wasn't you know that
wasn't what we talked about the terror
to hate father how I was going to behave
at school or anything like that so I
think a lot I think sometimes look it's
very difficult raising children in this
culture it puts a tremendous amount of
pressure on parents these days but I
think it is doable to you know that it
really does make a big difference how
the parents mediate the culture for for
their children know childhood I mean I
have a niece was eight and I spend a lot
of time with her and when you look at
what she consumes how she's marketed to
the way we sell things to young people
children is is become more sexualized
because sexual ization suggests maturity
and kids want to grow up rapidly and so
the idea of buying the snakeskin
skin-tight fat farm jeans at eight or
nine is very traffic suggest I'm getting
closer to this other thing out here much
faster
I mean I look at as I think the
marketing of culture is dot driving all
of this part of it is a fact that young
males white black whatever are the
target group for so many products so how
do you reach these guys you use sex that
annette permeated every form of selling
is hard to find any product it doesn't
use that tool objectification of the
female body we say like young people are
coming into contact with it we think
about you know twelve-year-old
thirteen-year-old boys and that's the
group that's always looked at
pornography that's why pornography has
so many adolescent images it's about the
prom queen it's about the Catholic
schoolgirl but the fact is is that kids
are coming into contact with porn not
just at eight nielsen that ratings
tracks usage among two to six year olds
of visiting three years old you know you
bring out though about the sort of the
end of childhood that children at age
two or six are already being treated to
these very adult fair is really
interesting though because it's
something that i pay a lot of attention
to this well because you know childhood
is often talked about as a as a 19th
century invention a cream
happen with the Industrial Revolution so
kids stayed at home because it used to
be three or four hundred years ago that
you went straight from swaddling clothes
to adult gear and you were sent out in
the field hard labor or you were married
at age 11 or 12 you were an aristocrat
boom full adult and then you know in the
19th century kids stayed home there was
an expansion at the age of childhood and
then really teenager is an American word
from the mid 20th century and one thing
that's really interested me as I hit my
30s I started noticing how many 30 year
old 30-plus year olds there were on
television that were doing nothing
related to adult and adult life Sex in
the City
Seinfeld Will and Grace you know what
other shows are there zillions friends
where they're all these like people who
have pushed childhood or adolescence
well beyond the age of normal childhood
or adolescence biological whatever
you're pushing right up to menopause
you're still doing good interesting to
know that simultaneously there's been
this marketing of adult fair to two and
six-year-olds it's like now we've got
this enormous period of time which is
really like adolescence which should be
a short period of time when you're
something you know this well I don't
know if it should be but what maybe I
think of as that period of time which
has now been extended from age 2 to age
40 if you count Desperate Housewives and
we're still sort of children you might
might even go beyond that significant is
that while they're inundated with this
culture and whether it starts with poor
nurse strippers I mean whatever it is
it's there and it's raunchy and it's
it's always about women performing this
one ritual of sexiness they are equipped
with very little information with which
to grasp this because over 80% of the
public schools that offer sex ed in this
country say just say no to sex and teach
abstinence-only so there's not a lot of
information with which to process maybe
they may be teaching abstinence Plus
which is a different age I've heard it's
a serious number I've heard the number
one third because our federal government
yes
it's funding and literally it means if
you get the federal money you may only
teach abstinence and the only thing you
can teach about condoms is a completely
distorted alleged failure rate of
condoms and the only thing that you can
teach about lesbian and gay sexuality is
that you get you're exposed to AIDS I
mean it's very dangerous misinformation
and one of the reasons why I'm so
opposed to censoring anything in this
area again I know nobody's advocating it
but well because the information that or
the critique that's put out can be used
by others it's not a reason to censor
what you're the information that you're
putting out but I get very nervous about
how where policymakers are gonna be
taking this yeah I'm a little work on
there on this issue and there there is a
lot to be concerned about with this with
abstinence education but one thing that
I've noticed first of all it's not one
thing they're like 700 curriculums and
they are enormous ly varied but one
thing that is very striking to me about
the curriculums that I've looked at is
that there is an attempt to do something
that comprehensive sexual education was
not doing and that is to try to place
sex in a broader understanding of what
is your what is your life goal you know
what kind of partner do you your husband
or wife do you want eventually how do
you imagine you know finding that person
how do you judge that person so they are
doing something that I think was missing
in the more mainstream it used to be at
any rate sex education unfortunately you
know we're in this we're in this
environment what's so polarized that
it's you know it's again the Scopes
trial terms where oh if it's abstinence
education then it must be just you know
teachers taking the time to actually put
sex in this larger context I mean so
many that teens I interviewed didn't get
anything like that all they got was
don't do it until you're married oh do I
do I think that sex education has ever
been taught well follow up with the
question you raised about obscenity not
to take up the entire panel so I
just want to confine it to the two of
you really briefly it's and I want to
just remark when I was reading up on
this I just came across I probably they
did it was a yearbook that in 1975 the
Supreme Court ruled that oral sex is can
be a crime against nature it was that in
your book I don't think that's quite
accurate but in 1986 the Supreme Court
upheld against a constitutional
challenge a law outlawing any oral or
anal sex between even between married a
married heterosexual couple that was
just over maybe a couple of years ago
that so the question of obscenity
justice vast and what it everyone is not
seems can come right extremes that seem
absurd but Pamela yeah that was a really
really good question I was responding
directly to Katie's question what line
do I consider to be appropriate the ACLU
to considered considered to be
appropriate and what I described is true
for every category of expression except
for sexually oriented expression where
the Supreme Court has created this
anomaly the so-called obscenity
exception you're absolutely right that
they last visited in 1973 in this case
called Miller versus California which
was decided five to four very
controversial the overwhelming majority
of law professors think that there is no
constitutional justification for it
basically the Supreme Court said even if
there's no evidence of any harm
whatsoever from this expression we
believe that it lowers the moral tone of
the community and I was thinking about
that actually in response to Katie's
question about what about this other
kind of harm it's exactly that
inchoate damage to the tone of this of
the community the corsa nning the vulgar
is a ssin of the community that was the
rationale for the obscenity exception
the reason why I disagree with rod
smolla who might otherwise generally
agree with when he says that a lot of
what we see could be prosecuted as
obscenity is that it's got a three-part
definition and I think the
of the changes that we've all been
talking about it would be very hard to
satisfy any three of those parts of the
definition the first one is that the
material has to be what has to appeal to
the prurient interest in sex and that's
defined by the contemporary community
standards and per inch for those of you
who don't know what it means the Supreme
Court later went back and said that
means a morbid or sick interest in sex
as opposed to a normal and healthy
interest in sex so you can tell how
objective that definition is but I think
you're saying what the cultural experts
are saying is there wouldn't be too many
juries who if they were honest would
find that too many things satisfied that
the second criteria and I think would
also be equally hard to satisfy from
what you're saying and that is that the
material be patently offensive according
to contemporary everybody's watching it
how can they voluntarily how can they
say it's patently offensive and the
third one which is defined by national
standards is it cannot have any serious
literary artistic political or
scientific value and that's why things
like music and and that was this
vacation at 2 Live Crew cases and in
Florida I mean all this language you
just described is so I mean it's rock
and roll it's hip-hop
it's all these cult expression that's
why this whole debate is so shaky but if
the language just does not work and
period interest Chuck Berry was pure
interest and so was Little Richard NWA
is period interest I mean I mean these
arguments so we've been using these
phrases you can apply them to such a
large section of what culture is that
they're not useful in defining the
things you did you may have be most
problematic do you think the language
could be improved to be useful or do you
think that there is no language that's
useful and in this era there's no less
there's no like because it's [ __ ]
because the culture shifts and we try to
move the language to address the culture
and the culture move some more it we
have these phrases
we're created to define a moment or a
piece of work under attack but they
don't work because pop culture popular
culture is a constantly moving a ship
what was the most outrageous thing and
this culture is now I mean I mean porn
we go back to jenna jameson thing
there's a book that was a best-seller
this year on a New York Times bestseller
list called confessions of a video vixen
which is part of the Jenna Jameson for
the hip hop generation of a girl who
they were now if you read Jimmy James's
book she's always like well I feel
conflicted I really should be there's a
lot of you know oh no it's really not
what you think it is it's all about her
transformation but the news is the
language they used to sell what they
could sell the problem with with the
language is that even putting aside
cultural shifts and geographical
variations even the very same community
at the very same moment in history
people are going to be conflicted and
the 2 Live Crew cases you may remember
there were two prosecutions for the
exact same work as nasty as they want to
be and in in both in Broward County
Florida in the very same year one was a
jury case one was a judge case and for
the very same piece of music they came
back with completely opposite verdicts
and so I think the only honest
definition is the one that everybody has
heard from supreme court justice Potter
Stewart when he said I cannot define it
but I know it when I see it so we have
to make that decision for ourselves so I
want to we're gonna have to move along I
just wanted for anyone he doesn't
actually know the specifics of that that
was a 1990 case right Nelson that you
live creative nasty as they ought to be
and in the federal judge declared it
obscene making it the first record US
recording group that was banned for
minors based on indecency for selling it
and and and really and I thought that
really if you look at Nelson's book he
talks a little bit about about Luther
Campbell who routinely invited women on
stage to strip and actually proposal
that a central issue in character in
this discussion because he helped
sexualize hip hop he's
who brought booty dancing and all that
stuff to the floor not and simulated
simulated sex acts on stage and the
whole next 20 10 years 15 years of music
videos were driven by a lot of the
aesthetics of what he creates he's
interesting this guy from Florida
Florida State again you know has a
central role in several levels of this
discussion both in terms of hip-hop and
in terms of pornography he also I just
get off this real quick but loosely
keeps coming up loser also it wasn't
black pornography as I grew up there
wasn't really black porn and any big
members until the late 80s they didn't
didn't exist there's some correlation
between hip hop and that I'm not quite
sure I can't I'm not gonna put the
finger on hip hop for that but certainly
pornography and hip hop have been really
good bedfellows over the last 10 years
have featured hip hop already been
hosted if you will the biggest selling
porn DVDs of all time so I want to just
be he'll only have a few minutes so I'm
gonna be really disciplined as we let
this section of the discussion go quite
a while so I'm just gonna ask one or two
questions on where we see the impact of
this sort of new unified world and then
I'm gonna ask for prescriptions but I'm
gonna ask you to be quick and brief in
Ariel I want to ask you first because
your book really talks about how
pornography has a porn a porno mindset
has spread into a more general raunch
culture and you talk about female your
10 the title of Ariel's book female
chauvinist pigs so I want to ask you
well first of all I want to ask you what
is a female chauvinist pig and I also
wanted to one I also wanted you to
comment on well as I said before one of
the things that I noticed reading your
book was how it elating it was and you
mentioned to me right before you called
me pervert that you had the same had the
same impression reading Andrea Dworkin
yeah so my question is what is that are
we art does that make us part of ranch
culture or aren't we
in some way I mean Pamela's here wearing
leather pants I mean aren't we all my
real question is where is this line how
where is the line and how much
of pornography is seeping into
mainstream culture what is the female
shape well there's it's it's meant to be
funny some people think it is something
people think it's like less offensive
thing I've ever heard the idea is that
if a male chauvinist pig was a guy from
years past who treated women like pieces
of meat than female chauvinist pigs of
today are women who make sex objects of
other women and of themselves and think
of this as sexual liberation and Katie
sent me this email where she said you
know I found parts of your book
titillating what do you think about this
am I just a pervert so your mother back
and I said you're just a pervert no but
then I a mother back I said I had the
same experience when Andrea Dworkin died
the moat you know the moat there's sort
of an icon of the anti sex symbol the
icon of the anti-porn movement she died
I wrote an article about her for New
York magazine and I had the same
experience I would be reading these
pages and pages of descriptions of sex
ads and sometimes I felt like I wasn't
sure if I was supposed to be offended or
masturbating you know and I and I think
that I mean I think that that's okay I
mean I think that you know to what
extent you're gonna find this stuff
titillating to what extent you're going
to participate in it you know that has
to that has to be grounded in what is
pleasurable for you and the point of my
book and what interests me about this is
how often I talked to young women and
grown women who had really taken all the
emphasis off of pleasure whether you
define that as simply sexual pleasure or
what casing an emotional bond you know
or some kind of intimacy that's going to
yield something more profound than an
orgasm however you define it I felt like
there was so much movement away from
that and on to just putting on a show of
sexiness and that's that's the thing
when you were saying earlier you know
this would be good if what it reflected
was that women were just embracing their
sexuality but the thing is you're only
embracing your sexuality
if booty dancing really is your
authentic way you play the percentages
I just find it unconvincing that this
many women this just happens to be their
thing you know there's as many ways to
be sexual as there are to be human and I
don't think that we've gotten to a place
where we just accept sexuality in all
its varieties I mean you think about the
last election when during wartime
you know we turned our attention to
making
an amendment to ban gay marriage which
was already illegal I mean I don't think
that weirdness loose relaxed puritanical
and yes I'm gonna have to wrap this up
and I have a couple urgent that I want
to have Pamela I gotta have I'm gonna
ask you to be really brief I'm sorry
this is a big question but in your in
your book you really talk about
pornography as destroying relationships
in marriage and the future of men and
women being intimate with each other and
it's interesting because your first book
also looked at in a different way at the
demise of marriage the starter marriage
so I want to ask you is porn really
destroying relationships
what are those statistics what is the
evidence of that that you have and I'm
giving you one minute well you know
there's there's no questionnaire that
you fill out when you go to divorce
court I'm just say that you know porn
did it and I don't think you could say
you know there's a direct causation
between you know pornography you know
broke up X number of marriages although
marriage lawyers that their 2003 meeting
did say 60% of those there said that
looking at too much internet porn they
had found to be a cause and divorces in
a way that they had never seen before
that said I think that again you cannot
say you know porn did it and divorce it
from all of the complexities that
entered and enter into a relationship
but when I did talk to people about
their experience and relationships and
not just in relationships but to young
people who are single it was clear that
pornography had in many ways been a
detrimental force and the way they
approached sex and the way their
partners approached sex for example you
would talk to a young woman and there's
one woman in my book I call her Ashley
24 year old from Baltimore and she told
me that basically all the guys that she
knows looks at porn they all go to strip
clubs on a regular basis you know when
she goes over to someone's house there's
always copies that maxim of Playboy you
know all of that and you don't even need
playboy really with maximun and FHM etc
lying around and what is this supposed
to tell her about the way her boyfriend
or potential boyfriend looks at her
about what he expects her to look like
the way that he expects her to behave
and you know she was in a relationship
at the time that we spoke and her
boyfriend would go to a strip club once
a month and would get a lap dance and
she said to him you know how is it
different if you go to a strip club and
get a lap dance here if that woman were
doing
to you on our sofa right here that would
be cheating why is it okay when it's in
a strip club and I think that a lot of
women felt that pornography had really
become part of their boyfriends or their
husbands experiences sexuality in a way
that then dictated to them or that made
them feel in competition with or
threatened by what what they wanted and
so the other thing I think that is less
talked about because we're so used to
talking about pornography is impact on
women is the effect that it has on men
and it was really interesting to me
because again I was mostly talking to
porn fans these were guys that said
they've had no problem with pornography
these were happy porn users and yet they
were telling me that they had found
their ability to have an orgasm with
regular in sexual intercourse had
diminished that often they had to
emulate the money shot if you were all
familiar with that from pornography they
would have to ejaculate on their
girlfriend or wives or whoever they were
sleeping with that tonight that night
space or breasts in order to achieve the
same sadist a satisfaction that they had
before they started looking heavily at
particularly internet porn trying to
wrap it up yeah many sexual problems
I'll get I hope hopeful get back to this
maybe with one of the audience questions
because I know you have some
prescriptions and in fact I'd like to
invite people who have questions to come
up please and line up in front of this
microphone and I'm gonna ask one more
last question that we'll before we start
audience questions and I wanted to ask
it of nidian and I'm sorry we'll get
back and we'll ask more here but
particularly I want to ask Nadine porn
is everywhere now this whole battle that
has pit you know sort of feminists and
Republicans against the perverts and the
civil libertarians about whether we
should regulate porn is there any point
in regulating porn now I mean is this
argument totally moot one of the things
you said is it's not moot because
broadcast is one of the sort of holdout
areas of our hypocrisy we saw that with
the Janet Jackson and Fiasco so that's
my question I just want to say where is
this argument on
censorship doesn't exist yeah well there
are still constant attempts to censor
not only through using the obscenity law
that the Supreme Court has refused to
find unconstitutional John Ashcroft was
already referred to while he was
Attorney General he beefed up the
resources that are the Justice
Department is putting into prosecuting
obscenity I mean at a time when we
thought that all of our resources had to
be fighting the war on terrorism
I don't think taxpayers realize how many
prosecutors are are tied up now going
after people who are voluntarily
performing for and watching
sexually-oriented expression on
television there is as you as many of
you know censorship through the FCC
which bans even indecent material that
is perfectly legal in other media so
that it is true I would not be able to I
can describe the famous Supreme Court
case that involved [ __ ] of a draft when
I'm on TV that gets bleeped out so and
yet you turn one channel away you're on
cable and you can be having you know
extremely sexually explicit material so
talk about hypocrisy and inconsistency
as a result of the famous wardrobe
malfunction last year there was a
tremendous amount of political pressure
to harmonize the disparate regulation of
broadcast and satellite and and cable
but by moving away from free speech so
that there are now bills pending that
would subject cable and satellite to the
same restrictions that are now imposed
on broadcast TV and almost nobody has
voted against it on either side of the
aisle it's very politically unpopular to
defend freedom for this stuff even if
you know all your constituents are
watching it I might want to invite three
the first three people and we'll take
questions in groups of three so if you
can say your question rather quickly
just because there's a lot of people in
line I see sorry about that
yeah I just wanted to say yeah that just
started out I do believe the censorship
of porn is almost moot at this point
cats out of the bag it can't happen and
it's not a legal battle if it is a
battle it's kind of one of survival at
least you know it was a girl who's
dating right now for me but I've also
wanted to know seeing as the
industry rivals the film industry as
well as the pro sports industry and how
much money that it makes every year how
that relates to maybe in an analogous
way you know the cigarette industry
targeting people who were very young and
getting them addicted at a young age or
you know how the money behind the
industry is as you know fueling the the
way in which it's overwhelmed our
cultures everything else and how the
companies are not social pioneers their
profit ears you know the guys and the
women you know who own these companies
are out just have two to six year olds
you know see that stuff and get hooked
and you know I I mean it could be miss
Dawson that that is not something that
affects them but it could be that it is
so I was just wondering how you all feel
that economics play a part in this
process we're gonna take questions and
groups of three so if the next person
could come up Thanks I want to thank
Pamela for your focus on relationships I
think that's an important and often
forgotten part of this discussion and my
question is I see similar things that
happen with men that get fixated on
pornography with the sort of I mean in
New York it's incredibly prevalent but
where I come from in Virginia it's very
common with sex toy parties and I see a
sort of a corollary among women not
necessarily with porn but not
necessarily exclusive from porn with the
use of sex toys which on the one hand
I'm in favor of you know exploration and
whatever but you know the use of sex
toys and pornography are largely
solitary activities and so I don't know
that well I don't know maybe men would
say that women's use of increasing use
of sex toys has affected the way women
look at sex and men as potential sex
objects but I was wondering if someone
could address that because it seems to
me sort of like the women's part of this
increasing objectification of sex
first I'm just gonna make a brief
statement and then I'm gonna ask my
question um I think it was Kay you
mentioned before that you're not sure
what exactly young women or young men
face and what we're calling a porn
culture and I just would like to say
that when you step into a child store
and the only dolls that are really for
sale are Barbie with her huge boobs and
those Bratz dolls with their extremely
sexual appearance whether that's right
or wrong I'm not saying I'm just saying
that's those are the only choices and
you go into limited to and Kohl's which
is very mainstream store and then you
have juicy written on a 12 year olds
butt and cleavage shirts and things like
that and also when you go into high
school and discussions of anal sex are
geared towards well yeah that feels good
not oh my god what are they dangerous
for the female or the g-string it's not
men's underwear it's vaginitis yeast
infections like these are not this is
just one option that mainstream stores
are providing so that's just a backdrop
of youth culture and my question is you
made a good point all of you made a good
point that there's one point of view in
pornography and I'm wondering how
without embracing that one point of view
of silicone and fakeness and hurting
women or whatever is projected in this
porn world is there any way to expand
our higher conscious of what we view
against what we're viewing and is there
also any way that we can change
pornography
not erotica because there's a lot of
room for that but pornography is there
any way to make it more women friendly
user friendly I don't know okay so the
quest the first question was about the
profiteering porn profiteering for
two-year-olds the second was the
solitary activities sex toys and and
porn and what's the woman's role and
sorry to truncate and simplify and the
third is there a way to expand or change
pornography in a more women's centric
way and I'm just going to invite whoever
wants to respond by female filmmakers to
make more female friendly porn and
that's been going on for quite a while I
think there is a market for it that does
exist but the core audience for porn is
men and that's what's driving industry
it's funny your comment you made about
the men going to strip clubs I mean I
definitely believe that that experience
has a very negative effect on men's
relationship with women I mean I know a
lot of guys who spent a lot of time in
strip clubs and I don't there's
something about sitting in a strip club
watching these and the looks on men's
faces I don't know if you guys ever
watched men in a strip club they look at
the bottom eyes related and I I do
disagree on one ground which is I think
that pornography actually is incredibly
varied I think there's an enormous range
of what's out there you know when I talk
to guys about what kind of porn they
looked at one guy said well it's kind of
like picking out what kind of ice cream
I want that you know tonight do I want
strawberry vanilla or chocolate you know
do I want amateur porn do I want lesbian
porn do I want you know anal porn and
they'll they'll flip their own shoes and
there are many women who produce
pornography and there are people who
produce so-called women's friendly
pornography and I think that one of the
interesting things again is I just want
to ground this in reality I would talk
to women and they would say well you
know I look at porn with my boyfriend or
my husband or whoever and I suggest it
because I know that he's really into it
and I want to seem like I'm sex positive
and like I'm adventurous and then he'll
think I'm really sexy if I propose
looking at it
so pick out stuff that I think he'll
like and then we'll watch it together
and then you talk you know and then one
more thing I don't really get off on it
you know I kind of get off of the fact
that he gets off in the fact that I'm he
thinks I'm getting off on it and
sometimes I think it's funny
and then you talk to the guy and he'll
say yeah my girlfriend wife whoever
suggested that we look at porn and I
guess I thought that was kind of cool
but to be totally honest with you the
stuff that she picked out I don't find a
turn-on at all there's you know it's
just too boring it's slow there's too
much plot and I want
but then what I really want to look at I
go and look at on my own so it's really
interesting that something that G people
think that they're doing to improve
their relationship somehow is actually
there's no communication going on and I
don't think it's improving either of
their sex lives
yeah and actually bring in the Barbie
business because Barbie came on the
market and I think it was 1959 and she
was modeled after a German dog that was
modeled on a cartoon prostitute Lily
Lily was a boy and you know they they
Mattel designed this doll with with this
German doll in mind and they turned her
into a little California girl with a
little more like a surfer girl but at
any rate when they test marketed the
Barbie on the public the the mothers
hated it they were so upset that that
Mattel was now going to market this
thing to their daughters but of course
it became a gold mine as it continues to
be today I guess but what I was going to
say is so even then we're dealing with
this market marketing problem and there
I you know the question is well what do
we do about these guys are people are
making money off there's no question
about it and that's why they're doing it
but I think that there still is more
that the public can do and the fact is
when there is public outrage these guys
back off because they don't like the
publicity so Abercrombie & Fitch for
instance was forced to take their they
had a catalog I think it was about a
year ago was it that was one century
soft board you know and people there was
an out there was an outcry about it and
they took it off the market so so saying
Thanks so you know it seems to me that
really you know there should be more of
that and people shouldn't see our side
as consumers too
that's right I mean I think the law is
not a very effective instrument in
dealing with this so I'd like to invite
the next three people to come up and say
what the warning who have the comment
about relating porn and sports and
cigarettes and profiteering to to come
up the next day I just wanted to say I
think that that's an excellent question
and we should continue to think about
that I would love to hear a response if
not regulation then what should it be
like a culture of great it should we be
cultivating a greater culture of disgust
or what would our because I think all of
us would agree that we don't really want
you know the profiteering sort of
mindset on two-year-olds we don't want
two year olds being sold dildos that's
actually the definition of illegal
sexual content that Justice Scalia is
pushing for he wants to call it
pandering and he think I totally
disagree with it that I want to put it
out there for your consideration that
it's you shouldn't judge it by the
content but you should judge it by how
it's being pushed including the audience
yeah so to speak thrusting thrusting
thrusting is a term by the way that
actually came up in the harper's debate
20 years ago and it means when when for
example a billboard is right in your
face and you can't avoid it so and
actually I should ask you whether you
are in favor against re and I are
actually said that he would weigh that
that's fine the concept is there was a
captive audience that can't avoid seeing
a certain expression I think if you're
going out into a public place like Times
Square you have to take whatever is
there you know you're on notice that
you're going to hear political speech
you disagree with as well as other forms
of speech you disagree with III I don't
like that exception outside of the home
or perhaps the workplace where you have
no choice to be right he was the
previous precedent executive director of
the ACLU and he had actually said in the
earlier debate but that was one form of
regulation that he could agree and I had
a wonderful response which was to Susan
Brown Miller but what about all the you
know feminist magazines and people who
are giving bortion think that that's
advocating more exactly
more than he said I would be more than
happy to put the porn magazines on the
back shelf if you would be willing to
put ms magazine and all those terrible
abortion advocating feminist magazines
on the back shelf to next three I ask
this question is a Korean woman who is
offended by stereotypes of the erotic
Asian woman and her body being errata
sized in Western media and culture what
are your views on pornography as
violence against women and as
perpetuating oppressive racist sexist
patriarchal systems in which we still
live I'm sure I don't need to remind
everyone that Parag Rafi is one of the
only industries that actively and
blatantly accepts and promotes racist
stereotypes of women and sexism hi my
question it's a comment and a two-part
question
we are living in this very hyper
sexualized culture but it's underscored
currently by this conservatism and I'm
just really fascinated what you might
think about is you know is our extreme
hyper sexualization and rebellion you
know with our governments agenda and how
what you're talking about the abstinence
only programs in schools and just the
education and young people are getting
today and the lack of information
they're getting and in light of that
there's a new campaign that Trojan
condoms has just put out and I'm just
curious if anyone on the panel has seen
that the Alexa line which is a line for
women and it comes from the women's
perspective and if you've seen that I'd
be curious to see what you think of that
is that those who know condoms or they
know their male condoms marketed towards
women under this guise of like a club
Alexa it's called
yeah
I know what they were selling I was just
curious interesting thing is people the
commercial doesn't necessarily let you
know what it is it a vaginal condom it
leaves you questioning but I I was just
interested in that as how they're
marketing it towards women and is it
effective and is it do women find that
offensive or are they excited about it
I'm interested to know what you all
think about what we can learn if
anything from how other cultures have
dealt with pornography specifically
cultures in Europe like France or
Denmark that are at face value much less
prude than America and have had at least
before the internet porn was much more
present in those countries than in
America and yet they seem to have much
healthier gender roles then Americans
broadly speaking and my my read on it is
about a you know in these countries
there's some much more of a cultural
identity to counterbalance the messages
that porn sends and one of the main ways
in which pornography kind of infiltrates
America in negative ways is that we
don't have more discussions like this on
public television or something so I know
you can't create a culture that will you
know give the other the alternative in
terms of gender roles that porn creates
but what how do you think we can
facilitate something more along the
European model I'm shocked that we
haven't discussed AIDS a bit more I
don't know okay the questions are racist
stereotypes violent stereotypes and
pornography cultural stereotypes second
what do we think of Alexa Trojan condoms
for women do we find it offensive do
people find it offensive and third how
do other cultures how other cultures
dealt with pornography perhaps the
European model more successfully in AIDS
I mean porn is without a doubt the most
racist consistent media expression in
the United States there's no doubt about
it you want a website it's the the
sultry asian girl the big dick black guy
in this hot spanish spicy latina they
use every every conceivable stereotype
to sell it and to me that is more
dangerous than the sex itself go back to
the very first question also touch on
some of these questions I don't think
that this is a reaction to the political
climate I think that it is big business
the goal here is profits and I think
that if anything it's more a reflection
of the technological advances and I
think the profits that are to be made
and I think but I would say that there
is a cultural message that's very
supportive of pornography and that what
I would say needs to be done rather than
legislating the issue is to have more
information and as Kay said to really
put it into context you know we have
speaking of education and high schools
many high schools in this country have
begun media education programs because
kids are so targeted by advertising by
marketing by media messages they don't
know the difference between the O'Reilly
Factor and a straight forward news
report they don't know the difference
between something that's targeting to
sell them something versus something
that's intended to inform them and I
think that similarly what's that sex
education kids need to have some kind of
understanding that this choreography is
a product it is created by people to
make money this is how it works these
people are paid and these images do not
necessarily reflect the reality of human
sexuality I ask you to respond to the
Trojan wash because while I agree that
this is about business and it isn't
caused by you know this administration
or this political climate I think it's a
pretty good fit for this political
climate because if you're an incredibly
restrictive environment why wouldn't you
turn back to these extremely old school
very retrograde ideas about gender and
sexuality it challenges nothing can I go
to the cultural of the last of the
reagan-bush
in years has repressed has tried to
shutdown has tried to restrict our
access what we see what we hear and
there's no doubt in my mind that the
culture is rebelling on every level
against that you think that it's a
rebellion in other words we wouldn't
have porn no but I'm saying that the
permutation of it into the mainstream
culture is is linked to a kind of [ __ ]
you exactly I'll take it from the
hip-hop point of view there's no doubt
that the lyrics and the imagery and so
much of it is driven by a sense of I'm
going to make my statement against that
over and over again and I think that
because there's a satisfaction that has
been going on for a long time that
hip-hop is part of because hip-hop
speaks directly to young males it drives
and informs a lot of their attitudes
toward the mainstream I want to say
something about the International
question and the and the violence
question they tied together because you
can't even show correlation between
exposure and availability of even
violent pornography and either violence
against women or discrimination against
women some of the cultures that are have
the lowest gender equality and the
highest rates of violence against women
pornography is completely censored and
unavailable along with other human
rights for example Saudi Arabia and Iran
and then the question was asked about
certain European cultures like Sweden
and Denmark and Germany were the rates
of gender equality and and are very high
and violence very low and there are no
restrictions at all on pornography in
terms of the racial stereotypes I just
want to use one example from my book to
illustrate that you know no two women
can possibly agree on whether something
is empowering or whether something is is
is is the opposite one of the exam
bullseye use is a cover from a lesbian
magazine on our backs of an
asian-american woman
donjuan who was her idea it was the 1993
cover and she's standing in a very
strong posture and she thought that this
showed encountered the stereotypes of
Asian women as being very passive and
that it showed that she was very strong
and in control and then there were some
other lesbian feminists who thought that
this was terribly degrading and debasing
and they attacked feminist lesbian book
stores that were selling the magazine
and ripped the covers off it so I think
you know what some people might see as a
negative racist stereotype is not seen
that way by other people pornography and
violence which I agree I think similarly
it's very difficult to say that
causation between the way a society
depicts gender and the way in which
gender functions in that society and
pornography I think it's apples to
oranges and there's so many variables in
terms of their politics in terms of the
way feminism is operated in this
particular countries that I think you
can't really compare and say well but in
Sweden they have pornography it's legal
and they don't have as much of a problem
with sexual violence I think that again
you know there's just too many variables
I agree with that but it shows that you
cannot prove that there are people to
come up I want to just point out I think
it's really interesting that no one
chose to address the AIDS question and I
wonder if that reflects a class you know
class anal sex and that one of the major
changes in pornography no you're really
doing your part to expand our I mean
there's whole lines of videos just anal
this anal that it's there's lines in
London and now if you watch porn the the
[ __ ] is not necessarily at a big
moment it's the anal sex section of and
it's crazy because I think that is
affecting I think guys are seeing the
stuff and asking a girlfriend for it and
in porn it may seem fun though the girls
are doing it don't seem that happy and
your connection with eggs I just I just
think that in general you know about
with a year ago
the black male porn star came down with
some virus we I think his name was Mike
James or something and that sent a shock
through the business and I think that
that was a very big way I mean the
industry really worked very hard to shut
down much talk about that but obviously
you have you're promoting potentially
unhealthy sexual practices and
everything you sell one interesting
thing is that in New York magazine this
week there's a whole package on sex and
there was a poll in which they asked New
York high schoolers what they did and
then they asked parents of New York high
schoolers what they think their kids did
and 12% so that they did that they
performed anal sex and 1% of the parents
of their kids did this that's a higher
percentage than the overall national
average according to you know earlier
studies so you do have to wonder if
there is some kind of influence of the
next person to ask your the next three
and your next I feel like a little bit
of the panel has kind of fallen onto the
old practice of having women as victims
and porn either in front of the camera
or in the bedroom apparently but what
about women as agents in pornography not
only in front of the camera but also
creating porn maybe more sex positive
women focus as opposed to this so-called
women focused porn
what about women's this age women as
agents there and also I feel like it's
been acknowledged that culture and
pornography its kind of gone back and
forth the chicken and the egg thing but
I feel like more times than not it's the
effect like the lack of comprehensive
sex education that has children looking
to porn that how to have sex as opposed
to like porn like children just going to
porn or maybe the lack of communication
or the Madonna [ __ ] dichotomy having
men look at pornography and that being
the cause of divorce and lack of
communication instead of like
pornography being the cause of that
right if you can discuss that
hmmm I just have a question you know I
feel that most people who like have any
correlation to the mainstream could care
less where what's shoved and when but we
do care about being bombarded by it we
do care about our children being
bombarded by it we do care about the
accessibility of it to them and the
people who wouldn't normally would say
even take it up you know if you're just
sitting there clicking around the screen
and there's a pop up
and here's a pop up and here's a pop up
and what are you gonna do because
they're ready you got anal you got like
3-way you got this you got horses and
all you're trying to do is like figure
out you know what
what encyclopedia means you know so
there's got to be some kind of
regulation to this this is ridiculous
and then you know you look around and
people nobody's in love nobody get what
you know nobody knows what love is
anymore
everybody's like well let's go you know
shove this up your ass more than love
let's get married have a few kids get
divorced alright we're good I'm curious
about whether you guys panelists think
that porn is ageist and how so there was
an episode on Sunday night of Desperate
Housewives in which a couple a
middle-aged couple on the show it was
revealed that they have a penchant for
making and viewing their own porn tapes
and this was immediately written off it
wasn't like really taboo because
Desperate Housewives tries to be kind of
edgy I think a little bit but it was
immediately just assumed you know that
that's weird we're not gonna let one of
the other couples wouldn't let their
children play together anymore so I'm
just wondering whether I mean just in
this example maybe if it were a younger
couple what would it be acceptable that
this you know that a married couple
creates and watches their own porn
that's very that's very specific but I
guess I'm just wondering what age group
might porn harm the most because it's
that I mean I'm not a user I don't
really know very much about the porn
industry but it seems like younger let's
say women are just younger people are
often the subjects of porn videos and
porn media so I'm just curious whether
maybe older people in general are
actually harmed more or kind of maybe
are more offended I don't know so we
have the questions what about more Pro
sex women made pornography since we
focused on sort of the other angle of
that and then the second question about
being bombarded by pornography and I
guess what to do about that and the
third is porn Aegis that's I think
that's really interesting because we've
really been talking about its impact on
children and how bad it is for children
and in a way it's cruelest to older
people whom who as it's as she mentioned
it's very ageist anyone care to respond
to these last one which is it's
interesting I don't know if I don't
actually think that porn is ageist the
pornography itself there's old people's
porn you can go and find that on the
Internet on the other side of the
spectrum I think what is really alarming
is that a most men who look at porn will
say the thing that I find truly
offensive is child pornography and yet
almost everyone I interviewed had come
into contact with child pornography
online often not deliberately there
they're made many ways to slip into it
and it is a slippery slope even though
we tend to think it's very defined
because child pornography technically is
anyone depicting anyone under the age of
18 and so when you have pornography that
depicts you know women over 18 as you
know schoolgirls as you know prom queens
you're looking at images of women as
young people and that's one way in which
people slip in because the guys say well
I actually want them to really look that
innocent I want them to really be that
pure another way is that men often
become interested in voyeuristic
websites and so they'll be looking at
nudist beaches for example and they'll
be looking at families and then though
there'll be a young woman there and
there's no sign there that says oh she's
18 and over I'm often it's very clear
that she's not and so she may be already
you know past you know have gone through
puberty so she may be
18 or 15 that's still technically child
pornography and then often they'll slip
even younger and say oh what does it
look like you know when a girl is just
developing and so I think that in that
sense there isn't an age barrier but
also in the consumer end there isn't an
there isn't a difference in terms of the
amount of harm or I would say it's the
the kind of harm is very different when
children look at pornography they're
learning to sexual EQ this is when you
know during adolescence boys are
learning what's sexy what's exciting and
often it's what they're exposed to and
they're masturbating to it you sort of
have this very potent chemical cocktail
and this is what they learn is exciting
but on the other end I talked to many
may people in their 30s 40s 50s and 60s
some who were addicted to pornography or
felt themselves addicted or compulsive
about it which is its own category but
many who were in relationships and said
you know I just found out that my
husband we've been married for 20 years
he's been looking at porn online late at
night when he's told me he's catching up
with work how am I supposed to feel that
he's masturbating to 20 year old women
I'm not getting any he's not having sex
with me and how am I supposed to compete
with that and that's just the reality of
how pornography I think operates for
people of different ages does anyone
else wanna do you want to speak to the
question about more Pro the thing I
would just point out about that is I
mean the women who are making
pornography you know there are a fairly
rare breed still I mean they're out
there but it's not the vast majority we
talk about women you know having agency
I mean that the vast majority of women
who go into the sex industry do so
because they're poor and the best
majority of those women stay poor so I
just think that we should keep that in
mind yeah I'm not just I would just want
to pose the question you know why do we
care that there's a pornography that
we're women you know our agents I mean
do we really think that this is gonna be
a better world because there's
pornography with women really freedom
isn't isn't everything yes but that
doesn't tell you there are right
you can talk about a right but that
isn't the same as a good okay you know
as I've been so I'd like to invite the
next and the last people to step up and
I just like we're gonna take one more
question sorry just the last one okay
two more we have time for two one or two
okay I'm sorry
well I don't know if you covered this
topic how ask the question and give a
little bit of background no background
how does the you know pornography and
the image of women influence judges in
divorce cases because it has become very
horrendous in some of the counties in
New Jersey and the children are being
affected as a result of that and it's
very serious this is a comment I'm
Judith Levine I've been talking about
this for about 50 years we could have
been having this conversation in 1920 or
in 1860 or during the French Revolution
and we could be talking about gambling
or the demon rum or blasphemous
pamphlets or comic books or
rock-and-roll or penny novels or the new
daily newspaper and all of these were
corrupting children and they were
breaking up families and they were any
civilization as we knew it and it's
always amazing to me that all of these
corrupted children managed to grow up
and sit in this room and have this
incredibly literal reaction to pictures
that are caricatures out of which we
make fantasies of licence and freedom
and craziness and disinhibition and
madness that's what pornography is about
it's not about copying and getting bad
and then you know growing up and it's
just I'm pleased to see that we have all
survived the terrible corrupting
cultures
because I knew in the United States for
12 years and look and what I could tell
that from my point of view the prime
biological malfunction is marking the
territory it means fighting and moving
everything [ __ ] and fighting
everything that moving they cannot fight
fight and [ __ ] everything obvious
reasons so we substitute it for computer
games for example violent movies or porn
my question is if we just remove this
substitute from our culture don't you
think that it will be much much higher
aid on our streets with raping and
killing I think that's just my question
okay so the questions are about judges
and pornography and divorce cases the
fact that we could have been having this
conversation at any time in history
about anything and yet we've all managed
to survive and talk about it and and
everything and wouldn't we be much
better off
maybe Maureen bond should answer that
one I'm sorry sorry
pornography together with other liberal
or progressive causes or we tend to look
at it and say oh but they said the same
thing about this problem and that
problem the other one and I think that
unfortunately that tends to deflect
attention from the question at hand
which is pornography and what the
effects are and what the reality is so
I'm just going to stick to that and I'll
just say one quick thing to answer
person's question which is in terms of
divorce cases the judges sorry the
lawyers that I spoke with the
matrimonial lawyers said that oftentimes
it's the joint custody is not granted in
those cases where the husband is found
looking at pornography online on the
family computer and that custody tends
to go to the mother only in that cases
so it has a terrible impact on fathers
who are involved in those kinds of
divorce cases like to speak to I mean
the comment about the light it goes back
to my language point earlier I respect
everyone's saying about pornography and
it's it's it's nefarious impact and and
I do think there is some nefarious
impact out there at the same time if you
look at the history of America we're a
country that loves fear fear is how we
sell everything and fear of sexuality is
one of the prime drives and his culture
from the very founding how we've
separated people how we demonize people
and how we've segregated people and to
act like that's not true is a lie so
pornography whatever it is it's not
going to destroy America any more than
rock and roll did or demon rum can I
just um it there has never been a
society that hasn't tried to regulate
and I don't mean legally but regulate
sexualities it doesn't exist and there
is always some attempt to explain sex in
a way that is socially valuable that's
just the nature of social or organisms
it's it's so I think that you know this
assumption that you know we're just
those of us who are concerned about the
porn of our culture are somehow these
flat earthers or people who are you know
aren't thinking about you know or
imagining the end of the earth I you
know I don't hear anybody talking that
way but we are talking about a culture
that
that is being coarsened and it's you
know it deserves discussion right it's
not enough to say oh well we've survived
well mr. perfect but that's not enough
Rebecca I wanted to say thank you all
for coming and thanks to the panelists
[Applause]
but I think we covered a lot of